star wars fans rejoice on october 30th
2020 the mandalorian returned for its
second season
when season one dropped during the big
initial launch of disney plus on
november 12 2019 star wars fans flocked
to the series which chronicles the
adventures of din jaron or mando a
mandalorian bounty hunter who for the
most part traveled alone
and has a super distrust for droids just
remember
yeah no droids i heard you you don't
have to say it twice
however when he sent to procure an
extremely valuable bounty for a
mysterious and wealthy
client jarrin changes his course and
protects the bounty
the child also known across the internet
is baby yoda
ultimately becoming a makeshift father
to the tiny powerful and mysterious
creature
though the first season initially seemed
like it would chronicle a different
adventure involving mando and the child
each week it closed out with a new
mission from ando who must now return
the child to his people
with allies like guild leader greek
karga alderaan native and army veteran
cara dune and mandalorian forge of the
armor mando is far from alone now but
what lies ahead is anyone's guess
so what happened at the end of chapter 9
mando and the child are seeking other
mandalorians who can help find the
child's mysterious homeworld to those
ends mando meets up with the cycloptic
gore quresh
played by a heavily disguised john
leguizamo who tries to double-cross
mando
and ends up telling the bounty hunter
that other mandalorians have been
spotted on tatooine i've spent much time
on tatooine i've never seen a
mandalorian there
my information is good i tell you once
back on the desert planet spaceship
mechanic pelle sends mando to the
supposedly abandoned town of mospelgo
where he meets the town's marshall cobb
van who's masquerading and prolonged
mandalorian armor
though mando is initially indignant and
demands that cobb remove the offending
armor the two men realize they have a
bigger problem to deal with
specifically the enormous crate dragon
jeopardizing the town
the two strike a bargain where mando
will help cobb van than the surrounding
tuscan raiders eliminate the crate
dragon saving everybody in the
surrounding area
thanks to this armor i've been able to
protect this town from bandits
sand people they look to me to protect
them
help me kill it i'll give you the armor
once they succeed mando and the child
set off once again but this time someone
is watching
and it's a pretty big deal if you
thought that the heavily armed and
tattooed man watching mando and the
child leave maspelgo might be boba fett
you're exactly right played by tamura
morrison who took over the role in the
prequel trilogy boba fett is watching
mando make off with his old uniform
and considering that he's the original
mandalorian bounty hunter in the star
wars universe fans can pretty much rest
assured that mando and boba will meet
sooner rather than later
beyond boba we know that moff gideon a
high ranking empire official who's after
the child
is sure to show up this season after
trying his hardest to claim the child
during the mandalorian's first season
mop gideon has revealed a powerful
darksaber and will definitely reappear
to wage war against mando and his allies
before long i will act in my own
self-interest
which at this time involves your
cooperation and benefit
whether or not boba fett will help mando
and the child also remains to be seen
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mandalorian are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one